good morning John when I was growing up
there was a TV show called Captain
Planet and the Planeteers I always knew
it was like a bad TV show but at least
it was a good message it taught kids
that the world was in danger and that
the power to save it is yours but when I
started my master's degree in
environmental studies I was surprised to
find a lot of ambivalence and even
outright distaste for Captain Planet
that's weird so I wanted to talk about
it first though a synopsis Gaea realizes
she's been napping for too long and that
humans are at it again this was poor
silly humans so she gives some rings to
five teens and they get special powers
and can work together to call a blue guy
with a mullet and bad puns and I like
puns these ones are just bad the idea is
that it's half fun adventure and half
here's what you can do to lessen your
impact on the environment
Machel week four loads of laundry and
that's how for the first season at least
it was sold to a ridiculously
star-studded cast Whoopi Goldberg meg
Ryan levar burton sting and this greedy
big nosed rat looking guy poisoning the
water supply played by oh my god Jeff
Goldblum why it's either the police
station or the zoo the entire project
was conceived and funded by Ted Turner
who also owned the TV stations that it
ran on so why do I a definite
environmentalist have a problem with
this well kids shows have to have
villains but when that dynamic is being
applied to real world discussions and
issues that villain becomes a straw man
for someone real they're caricatures
subhuman evildoers destroy the
environment for fun almost all of them
with some kind of physical deformity and
many coated to be lower-class for some
reason most of these villains work in
extractive industries timber mining oil
energy and we never see any examples of
this work being done responsibly one of
the villains is a garbage collector like
why is that bad the lesson seems to be
that this work can't be done sustainably
and the people who do it do it because
they're monsters does anything
like more than being mean it's being
sneaky that isn't fun for the people or
families who depend on that work and
it's also not honest it might to some
look like a bunch of rich people living
in big buildings made out of mind
minerals with lives powered by fossil
fuels portraying the people who provided
those luxuries as evil like Ted Turner
has a nonzero number of private jets we
don't rip trees out of the ground for
fun we do it to build homes and make
paper we don't drill for oil so we can
dump it on the ground we drill for oil
because people buy it so that they can
get to work into the grocery store the
people who work in extractive industries
are real people not pigmen and
environmentalists have to work with
those real people when trying to get
policies passed they become their
friends or at least their colleagues and
seeing examples of being literally
dehumanized by the movement that now
suddenly wants to have a good faith
discussion isn't helpful I'm not saying
the Captain Planet did no good people
did learn good behaviors and it created
a group of young people who loudly
supported environmental regulation and
sustainable energy but a lot of that
energy came from vilifying a lot of
people who had to swallow their pride
and come to the negotiating table
despite being portrayed as monsters
because they helped provide the energy
and resources that we all use I know
that children's television is not the
place to go for political nuance but
maybe that's a good reason to not have
children's shows about politics if it
was only about respect or love or
appreciation for the environment that
would be fine but it's not and while
some of the after episode mini-lessons
provide nuance the stories rarely do it
looks to me like an intentional
formation of a rift teaching children
that the problem is bad humans not hard
problems and that when people disagree
it's because they are monsters who love
to destroy beauty it looks a little like
a microcosm for all politics these days
Captain Planet helped us win some good
policies but in the process it deepened
a rift we did that and I think it's
worth thinking about
John I'll see you on Tuesday